une bouteille en verre utilisé puis
rendue contre quelques francs puis
réutilisé et ce jusqu'à 40 fois c'était
le principe du verre consigné mais avec
les années 60 début d'une nouvelle ère
celle tu prêtes à consommer et à jeter
expéditif et elle me repose
l'emballage perdu gagne les ménages en
verre ou en plastique
il a conquis les fabricants de
bouteilles je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse imaginer de revenir tous azimuts
à la consignation la consigne snobé par
le progrès et par les consommateurs
moi je suis folle vers perdu est-ce que
je suis une femme dit sans vagues et
j'ai pas le temps
les verts perdu lui est recyclé donc
récupérer broyer fondu pour devenir une
nouvelle bouteille le procès des quinze
fois plus énergivore que la consigne le
nettoyage qui va avec
en 1981 l'oscd eux préconisent donc un
retour à la consigne d'autant qu'il
générerait des emplois mais rien n'y
fait en 1982 une journaliste certes une
potentielle explication dans cette
affaire de puissants intérêts sont en
jeu qui ont réussi jusqu'à présent à
faire reculer le pouvoir public des
groupes de pression en ce moment-même
agissent sur la communauté européenne
pour imposer leur politique du
gaspillage et empêcher tout retour mail
mot de regret à la possible les
consommateurs européens doivent le
savoir
sans compter que pour les industriels
l'emballage perdu c'est tout bénef
danger vous vendre du vin de l'eau
minérale ou la bière ils vont non
seulement ce produit mais ils vendent
également un emballage à l'emballage qui
coûte cher et que l'on jette à chaque
fois et très souvent d'ailleurs les
fabricants de ces produits sont
également des fabricants d'emballages
c'est-à-dire de bouteilles quasiment
plus pratiqués la consigne est
officiellement abandonné en 1999 au
profit de l'emballage à usage unique une
région fait néanmoins de la résistance
dans les grandes surfaces comme dans les
petits commerces c'est l'alsace à un
moment où on parle beaucoup
d'environnements d'écologie je pense que
quelque part prendre le verre le
consigne est passé faire partie de cette
mouvance déchets option consignes ces
dix dernières années certains commerces
et des associations ont remis la
pratique au goût du jour à leur tour des
édiles municipaux des députés et des
ministres envisage le retour à la
consigne pour les bouteilles en verre et
même en plastique
[Musique]